hey guys it's Deena and we are coming to
you live from our car in the occupied
West Bank town of El Buda and we had to
seek refuge right now because clashes
broke out between Israeli soldiers who
were firing live ammunition as well as
rubber-coated steel bullets against
Palestinian protesters young men just up
the street who were throwing stones as
well as Molotov cocktails so at the
advice of everybody who we went into the
car to seek refuge and we definitely
heard the live ammunition I'm with my
colleagues right now and I'm gonna
switch to the mic I'm gonna switch to
them
this is shadi and this is darriel and we
were actually and Guevara is right here
we were actually doing something new we
were filming virtual reality darriel is
holding the rig right now and we're
trying to because it was you know isn't
quite an action-packed scene and we were
gonna give you and we did a little bit
at 360 why don't you tell them what
we're doing in the VR darriel and make
that 360 degree view I think you can
move around and tell them how this is
the casing is created and then how many
go people like it was 3d printed by my
god we no name that our colleague of
Samara tiny in Doha right yeah
do you have a 3d printed very flimsy and
broken like 15 pieces already so Dario
was there
Dario was Dario was really keen on on
filming this even though there were like
no shots being fired they were up about
a couple of lovely I'm gonna get on the
car for a second just to give them a lay
of the land because it sounds like it's
kind of safe right now so just to give
you guys to situate you in terms of
where we are it's raining so I think
it's cleared out of it as I mentioned
earlier we're in the West Bank town of
an Buda this is Friday after prayers up
the street right here was where the
Palestine young men were protesting as I
mentioned they were throwing stones as
well as Molotov cocktails we saw down
over there was more the center of the
clashes where Israeli soldiers were
responding with
live ammunition as well as tear gas and
rubber coated steel bullets this is the
West Bank town of Abita and nearby
overlooking here you can see if the fog
is a tome and the fog rolls in this is
an israeli settlement this is the close
proximity that Palestinians live to
Israeli settlements which are here in
violation of international law that is
the consensus of the international
community about Israel disputes that
this is there's really settlement of sub
bullets that means Jewish Israelis live
here you can hear more I guess you can
hear the firing it hasn't stopped yet I
see all your messages guys thank you for
saying stay safe we're pretty far away
from where everything is happening right
now but that is the settlement and that
is why okay we're back in Tennessee to
minimalize your hats I'm asking if they
came from the classes STS on the field
he thinks that this class is up there
and people throwing stones or should
come at me on his last fight he said
there was live ammunition
ishka mention you have a gun someone got
about fellow Feeny
when Palestinian got hit and was taken
to the hospital over there oh I dish it
up his knew it I'm asking how close are
the Israeli he's saying they went on
they went back to where they're from and
sorry about the rain guys and Tyler's
each animal has a hat whenever this
might be a narc oh well I want to ask
them what were they doing and what were
they fighting for the action I'm licking
my machete nmf canva but still home
nation - on the catalyst in Mossad why
are you throwing stones because they are
they said of occupying our land occupied
our lands and they you know they want to
get it back that's what he's saying
basically
Oxana they're saying the oxalic so what
is she saying they were lux I'm asked to
return two bears of course Oksana Hermia
the locks administrator what's the
importance of a mask and that's you yeah
the two moths from the holy sites belong
to the and the and the Israelis occupied
it he said the Israelis are occupying it
for long I'm giving a rough translation
of what I'm hearing it's ablation why
are you covering your face they
shouldn't let they which I've shown that
finesse he says because he doesn't want
to be known something to see if they are
identified then the Israeli soldiers
will come and then basically get arrest
them in their houses Oh sonic Mac it's
happened to him where he has been he was
imprisoned he said for two years shut up
so I got shot he's giving accuse on what
to do here hermano if I do an additional
have a slam home he's saying no no bono
because through nothing he was arrested
he was he was basically arrested from
his home potentially he was arrested on
his home he was in prison for two years
and in the prisons that are booked they
they hit him woman he said they broken
no it's basically just to the car
we're hearing that being fired and
closes so maybe we should we should go
back into the car this is a live or fire
that sounds like it's getting closer
yeah so we're going to get back into the
car guys as you can see trying to factor
in a first life things fire than being
on the side of caution so we're back in
the car tell us what's going on hey can
we wipe the lens can I use it yeah sorry
guys here we go
it's rain all over and we're trying to
wipe the screen 149 people injured how
often do we do situations like this
happen especially in the last couple
months of unrest
Hegar is a local she claims she is one
of our colleagues she lives inside
Israel she's an Israeli citizen and
she's on our team this week and so she
knows she follows very closely what's
happening on the ground so to talk to us
about the last couple of weeks of unrest
it is a settlement and it's also the
commands of the Israeli army in the West
Bank so it's a hot spot for a lot of
tensions so almost every day
and the army is using live ammunition as
laws router coach bullet yeah big ladder
and yeah I mean Robert Koch bullets and
some reason he's really army considers
it to be like legitimate snow lethal
force even those people are actually
very surreal like I know that in two
separate incidents in to be Co you want
aerial strike try to figure out what
these guys are doing over here so you
can't drive and host at the same time
okay so your yeah no you should not okay
guys just hope what's going on here
Heights do you know we're still in
Vietnam and the occupied West Bank it's
a town that is right next to it I'm
alone where we've been reporting from
and staying and there were just there
was just a lot of unrest right now
between Israeli soldiers and Palestinian
protesters who live here
policy and protesters were throwing
rocks as well as you saw Molotov
cocktails shadi this is getting closer
to the clashes turn around
and they had what you know appears to be
all the tops which is that it had the
coke-bottle shed yeah okay what's going
on over here this is I guess so if you
yeah I'm shooting one so it's very far
down the hill don't worry though we're
very far I think we shouldn't get closer
to where we and so when we were
overlooking do you see the crest up in
that building
yeah pass that another five or six block
okay
so it's down the hill we're very very
far what would be interesting possibly
is to walk into that store and talk to
the bag I just got a message I just
gotta make a keypad Donna get on the
Cyrano and asking I'm not intersecting
Hornaday they live right here shame to
see at home what's happening okay I'm
running you my name is maja okay you're
speaking every I'm sorry I mother / my
baloney Anna and it honda cr-v nothing
so and the another saying there's really
soldiers are shooting live ammunition if
the mmm candid photos you have meant for
him embolism until - are you scared yeah
you are scared yeah the Bliss with her
mother you go home this look at how big
that no no yeah it's gotta be no but
yeah she's all I know he's they're
saying the house is right where the
clashes are happening so they don't want
to go home cuz they can't go home
because he thought my father
oh he's saying he got he was here uh
Berhad that he was hit by a bullet in
the past and so that's why they don't
want to go home dear bad luck okay yes
uncle
hello Ellen enough Cydia yes you see
Lake have some had an internet pie he's
like I don't want to end up in jail as a
member that could be in some thick and
she then I told you if you don't want to
be she is shown on camera go so so like
that well us they really they really
want they really want to be filmed some
of these kids here it is pouring rain
goes I turned the camera on me sorry it
is pouring rain we were outside throw
this guy's running I don't know so the
interesting thing here is then even
though there's a lot of unrest going on
right now it's almost like life goes on
as usual for a lot of these people
earlier I was speaking to a young man
who was a father literally with his baby
in the street and I was like are you
scared he's like this is this is normal
these protests are especially I guess
intense on Fridays which is the day that
people have often the day they go to
their prayer so after prayer is when the
protests began and this has been the
case ever since the local time here is
what
it's 2:30 p.m. I would say this has been
ongoing since maybe 12:30 or 1:00 about
45 minutes ago I think is when they
started firing live ammunition the
Israeli soldiers and that's when we
started to sort of take cover and try to
get a safe place this is occupied West
Bank baek's West Bank town of Abita
nearby and Israeli settlement with
federal struggle
maybe explain to the audience that are
now joining us what did it why it is
that there's been clashes ongoing on
Fridays the guys you were talking to
earlier if people missed it missed their
life that they were talking about
fairies in their classrooms you couldn't
allow some mask maybe just sort of
explained to folks that while you can
show them Outsiders or something but let
them know so let me just aim the camera
outside there are so basically guys
there's been a wave of unrest here for
the past two months the unrest again in
Jerusalem it was instigated by what
Palestinians suicide I guess aggressive
attempts from the Israeli government to
take more of their laksa mosque compound
which the Palestinians say belongs to
them and it is an occupied East
Jerusalem so the epicenter of the latest
unrest was Jerusalem it's then shifted
to the occupied West Bank
now just for some context here the West
Bank has been under Israeli military
occupation since 1967 this is an
occupation that controls every single
facet of Palestinian life from movement
to economy to where you can okay we're
back and okay so guys it's morning so
we're in a car we think that we think
that the confrontation between policy
and protesters and Israeli soldiers is
still ongoing that's why a lot of people
including us
sought refuge Prakash I see that you're
asking what's going on there
we're in occupied West Bank town of
Abita which is close to an Israeli
settlements are goats this is the site
of unrest and clashes that broke out
between Israeli soldiers who responded
with live ammunition and rubber-coated
steel books to Palestinian protesters
mostly young men who were throwing
stones and this is where we are you can
still see some people are these guys
these little kids I was speaking to
can't go home because their home is
where the clashes are and they don't
want to get hit at the same time they're
just kind of out on the street chillin
daddy's trying to see as anyone we're on
the livestream I'm gonna point the
camera away while I talk to you if any
of the guys here will talk to us but I
just pointed the camera toward them and
they told me to point it away to see if
anybody wants to be interviewed or not
we're not going to anyone who doesn't -
okay so we have to translate
sonica and they're here to bring the
message that all the Palestinian people
is read Alaska and the shoulders and
authority to stop the security
coordination with Israel in diet home
okay what is he hoping to achieve
okay can you guys let me know are you
hearing so now
sorry about that we're having some
technical difficulties oh we're back
we're back
Gina we're back you guys can hear it can
you tell me hey and you guys who are
watching can you tell me if you see so
or not we left are you where we left off
yes the Sun is back okay the time is
back so I don't know where you guys live
but we're ending a few blocks away from
where there have been clashes
I'm just asking to be quiet
we can't trick vodcast - awesome don't
know I'm sorry s they were talking to
him and I want to continue to talk to
miss a performance enhancement mikitani
was actually here throwing stones but he
just came in solidarity with those who
were Astrid Ephram what's your goal
follow me come on to the world into the
Israelis that the muscle is Palestinian
and it's for the Palestinians and
they'll do whatever it takes to defend
can you explain for an American audience
the significance of our lifestyle
Americans don't know okay so an optimal
compound in Jerusalem is one of the
holiest sites in Islam but it's also
holy to Jews and Israelis or a recent I
guess moved on the part of Videha darken
you can better explain a couple of
months ago more and more Israeli members
of parliament started going up to
election and to demand that soon that
will be able to bring their own oil and
we can see that and
which doesn't allow to play in the juice
reduce call at Temple Mount and they say
it's also holy to them but every time
that Israelis wrong with leadership and
stuff 15 of the big acts of provocation
when Ariel stood on the prime ministry
then went and visited the world you say
love is for all the Arabs and all the
Muslims in the world and that they want
to defend it planning obviously it's
raining guys we can't have the belt
sound some of the earlier one no no we
don't want to show them talking to me
because they don't want their parents to
see number one number two I ask them
what you were doing one of them said I
came to the great Palestine the one of
the interesting things about this latest
wave of unrest has very much been led by
Palestinian youth kids there is and
we're not showing them right down no he
got in the screen so he might want to be
interviewed
you can't wait this why not aim you like
it as well
no okay today we have been frustrated a
lot of them a lot of words cuz they
don't and they have nothing for them
they've grown up knowing nothing about
veiled negotiations of course in the
last 20 years have been failed
negotiation up in negotiation that has
delivered nothing for them all they know
is a life under occupation Israeli
military occupation that restricts every
single moment of their life as well as
daily humiliations at checkpoints so
they grow up seeing this and they grow
up seeing clashes like this it looks
super super more than happy fun so I
asked them juicy classes or video for
the residential neighborhood in India
where they live there are you know there
are there's violence there's live
ammunition being fired and people are
just being you know watching while
standing and watching sadly was normal
so can you ask him what sort of what's
the solution that somebody in his
generation that he wants to see I mean
what's the solution to this yeah the
conflict as a whole hundred thirty and
we then we put forward a lot of requests
to Israel for a solution including a
two-state solution but Israel in his
eyes wants war and does not want peace a
lot of people are complaining about
sound so I'm gonna get really close to
you guys I'm doing the best I can
sorry guys so just so you know our phone
you know got caught in the pouring rain
our mic is toast and so the audio we're
trying to scream as loud as we can but
this is the best we can do
just bear with us why are you covering
your face
immediate the medicine ethical or Oh
yummy yummy - she um to ship utilize
school ethical off in long story short
he said is basically covering his
identity is trying to control its
identity there's an Israeli I guess
Intelligence Unit called our step back
over there that are constantly arresting
young Palestinian men like him he said
whether it's here in the West Bank or in
or within Israel and so and there's also
informants he said so they don't want to
be identified because they don't want to
be arrested man let you think I'm and
I'm gonna just show people that looks
like over there without these guys
getting it if they don't want to get it
so if you want to explain what we're
seeing up ahead some people know yeah so
we're basically a couple of blocks away
from where the clashes broke out check
out that guy there's still some press
over there some people with their faces
are wrapped so we're trying to be very
careful to not capture people who don't
want to be on camera identity and to be
known because they're afraid of around
have to get really close serving in his
opinion growing stones is an act of
nonviolent resistance but yet it's
enough to get arrested and so what
happens frequenting is that the Israelis
will come and arrest young even kids
from their homes and they're actually
tried in military courts I think it's
real fun of the only country that tries
children and military courts so he's
saying we throw stones he wasn't
actually doing it today but that is an
act of nonviolent resistance fit for
Israel that's grounds to arrest you and
put you in jail yeah and why he thinks
that throwing rocks is nonviolent issues
and it open
yeah Johnny the husband didn't hear
enough there was the Australian anything
compared to this really to have all this
weaponry in all these arms what is a
rock but I'm there
my daddy feel it but it wasn't ice bill
my fork you can have the kimono there's
a fight where there's really responds
with live ammunition and with me the
same thing
anything that rocks are not nonviolent
their peaceful issue in this era in the
most ability Miami I mean Jack I don't
know the solution
they're not Amanda Morris there for me
we full share publishing I did the
workshop he very warm up about her let
me pull ahead
again that they were trying to send a
message what he called the occupation
that's how I was referred to here
sometimes instead of saying Israel they
refer to the whole state of the
occupation that day you know except they
will protect that locks them off and
that he cited the dawabsheh family a
family in occupied residential education
had to be a title that were burned alive
by an Israeli settler so that is still
very much on the minds of the
Palestinians here there was that
included a baby it will be maximally
night at the White City attention baby
and the mother and the father died the
Lord where are we went to this and this
is okay here we go we're back if you
just joined us we are right now in the
occupied West Bank town of an heater and
it's raining right now and we basically
went to our car was standing there
seeking refuge both from the rain and
from the pushes that broke out a couple
blocks up over there you can see there's
still ambulance that was sorted the end
of the street and the classes were down
the street what I mean by classes is
that they were polishing and young men
throwing stones at Israeli soldiers
there's nearly soldiers responded with
live ammunition as well as rubber-coated
steel bullets that's when we left and a
lot of the press showed up and because
it was not fake we're talking to some of
the young men here a lot of them don't
know if their face is shown they say
because there are Israeli intelligence
units up there that will come and arrest
them later I was just talking to a young
man here who's here in solidarity and
with the Palestinians he wasn't actually
throwing stones but he was telling me in
his opinion that when young Palestinian
men throw stones that is not an act of
violence that of the peaceful means of
resistance and he says that we asked him
why is it peaceful you're throwing
stones
he said compared to the sophisticated
weaponry that the Israeli army has what
is a stone so that's where we are right
now I'm just with some context and be
tough and I don't know if you could see
the settlement over here shadi come with
me I was seeing when I occupied with a
ton of a Beautif
unrest basically broke out I'm gonna try
to get out of the ring after Friday
prayers here the situates year we are in
Alberta it is a Palestinian town and
just up the hill right now if you can't
really see because it became foggy a
place with umbrellas shoddy just up the
hill is an Israeli settlement called so
good it is one of two Israeli
settlements that overlooks the remote my
area I don't know I think of it this way
said wealth is one of two Israeli
settlements that overlook this area the
other one is beit el where clashes
normally break out so they are really
literally overlooked by so by
settlements these settlements are in
violation of international law that is
the consensus of the international
community it means that Jews are able to
live there right next to policy and
Israel disputes that of course Lena's
Jacob Yakov
oh there's what's going on what are you
doing here because I want to go alone
from there million from the Jew cheese
sandwich to me I think you dance really
Oh Tina Stefan okay I'm gonna camera
Dina is talking to someone who just
called to make sure that we're all fine
and so we're taking some refuge here so
I'll just reiterate what we're doing
here and I'm pointing it toward myself
just because there's a lot of
young men here who don't want to be
don't so I'm trying to respect that so
we are a couple of blocks away but it
looks like it's nothing closer oh people
are running okay we should get in the
park we're gonna get it get in the car
get in the car nice hot guard she's in
the store
okay cold this hole where the fuck did
she go she went this way yeah okay you
guys so wait go interview somebody so we
ran into the car watch out watch out and
when I waited to get food I'm gonna go
get her okay she's everybody you can't
see anything unfortunately because the
rain is covering it but we basically saw
the young men running down the street I
guess the the unrest has moved down this
way so they told us to go away so our
colleague is in the store over here
I left my umbrella back there and I
swore on life
okay guys we're getting out of the car
again and we're gonna go into the store
where hugger is interviewing some folks
because the clashes were moving pretty
close to us so I'm going to pass back to
so I think the screen is a little bit
wet let me just fix it
thanks I'm sorry the thing we saw a
bunch of young men running down the
street and we took our cue to get away
in case anything happened it seems that
the questions are moving the thing is
epidemiologist or right here so I talked
to the air but just want to get a sense
they know a lot if I'm doing some of
this yeah you think okay his mom is over
there and see she is she's working here
as well so we just want to ask you guys
I mean show up to me it's just it's an
outsider it seems very rare that in the
middle of her visit Palestinian
residential community there's classes
like this breaking out there's live
ammunition being fired by the Israeli
soldiers have you got preferred okay
we're not guys we're back so up for them
here is the owner of this store and as I
was saying before we were interrupted an
outsider it's really bizarre that these
kind of things break out in the middle
of her is a residential community but
one of the facts of life here is that
life goes on so then this is another
issue Yanni already even though acute it
was it had to make a better Amanda not
weird he's like a force it's not their
thing we were born in these type of
conditions and we're we're used to these
kind of opposition get the time while
he's talking you think wherever a
community that lives under the well take
it out there because we're back live so
you guys are gonna get a little so this
is um we're getting juice juice given to
us by his mother who owns the store you
can see some young men who are coming in
for refuge here and you're also about to
see me and hugger well dip in the corner
but you're gonna see a little bit of
behind the scenes of Dina filming an
interview with this man who's inside the
store and we'll have a piece from coming
out later so stay tuned for that
so Darrell is just getting set up
well until Vario gives us the cue Dina
can control and this is a service a few
blocks away those clashes right behind
me there's people
we're live again so everybody we are
live as you saw from
so we're live right now hi guys
yeah let me just sign us out so we're
live right now from the scene of clashes
in the West Bank
there was thank you there was that were
rocks at Israeli soldiers and there were
soldiers who we heard were firing live
ammo there was all kinds of clashes
happening now we're a couple of blocks
away from it taking some refuge along
with all the